but anyway going back to rational
physics
so
like i i remember like think i was like
we set off ears on a podcast before like
our main fears oh no no we did an
episode where we talked about our fears
right we talked about stuff like that
no we we talked about what was like
huh was i scared of like tight spaces i
remember we were talking about
we talked about like crawling into tight
spaces yeah yeah because you were
talking about the cave story yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah cause like i remember
like i i just realized this as i was
taking another piss where most of my
rational fears come from um and yeah it
is from horror movies right yeah and
it's specifically from horror movies
that i would watch as a kid and that's i
think that's why like i [ __ ] detest
horror movies because i remember
like most of the horror movies i've
watched in my life are between the age
of like
five to ten years old right and the
reason for this is like every time i'd
go to my cousin's house
he'd put on a horror movie right how'd
it start is i'd go around to my cousin's
house and be like oh can we go to dragon
ball z can we watch dragon ball z and
every night and so like they put on
dragon ball z and i'd be [ __ ] into it
right and then all the parents would go
off and do their own thing and you know
they would they would they would ask
like the older cousins to take care of
the kids as soon as as soon as the
adults left they were like
yo you want to see a horror movie
you want to see someone get butchered
and i'm like no that scares me it gives
you nightmares
huh how old are you between like five
and ten years old
[Music]
a little [ __ ]
young yeah so i remember i think i was
like seven or something and i will i
would like what okay so i'm gonna say
the irrational fear okay
so
every time i approach my car
and it's just like in a in a car park
could be empty could be full right um
but i'm by myself and it's dark
first thing i have to do check the back
seat make sure no one's in it
second thing i have to do i have to like
go under and check that there's nobody
hiding underneath my car that every time
i i like
like nine percent of the time i do it
because i don't feel safe unless i do it
right what's gonna be under your car
okay here's here's the monster here no
no here's the reason why okay so
when i was about i can't remember it's
like between five and seven i think i
was like seven years old uh i go to my
cousin's house and of course it's like
god it's a horror movie time again i'm
like no please no it's like no it's
we're putting in the horror movie and
this time it's [ __ ] urban legends
um is it good it's it's uh like i don't
know if it's good i was it [ __ ]
scared the [ __ ] out of me as a kid i'll
tell you that and i've never watched it
since
um but uh you might get ptsd if you're
watching now honestly it'll overcome
your fear or maybe maybe it's it's like
a slasher horror movie so it was like it
was like 90s so that's when like slasher
horror movies were in like screamier
yeah the screen mirror so like that's
that's kind of the horror movie era that
i grew up with and that's the kind of
horror movies that traumatized me yeah
um and i remember
um it was this guy i can't remember the
exact movie the exact things that
happened but i remember it was surprise
surprise about urban legends so you
you'd have these urban legends that were
spread out and sometimes these urban
legends would come true i can't remember
what the exact urban legends were um but
i remember this one scene
um it was it was a guy who was basically
dressed up as death and he had a scythe
right right
and so i think part of the urban legend
was
that there would be this guy in the back
of your car while you're driving and
this actually happened in the movie
there was there was this person driving
the car and how he died was someone
emerged from the back with a [ __ ]
scythe and just [ __ ] chopped him up
to death right right and of course as a
kid that [ __ ] terrified me because i
remember thinking
if if i ever get if i ever grow up and
get my driver's license at any point in
the dark someone could come up from the
back seat and [ __ ] stab me in the
neck or [ __ ] slice my neck open i'm
and so and so
like that is just ingrained into my
[ __ ] mind but the second the second
death in that movie or maybe it might be
the third or the fourth i can't remember
so this so this rumor gets spread around
right
that uh there's there's a guy in the
backseat that you can you know there's a
serial killer and this is how this
person died
and so of course the fourth guy he
thinks he's better than this he goes
towards his car he's a bit scared but
what does he do he checks the back seat
of course he's like
i beat the system it's so dumb
out of nowhere the guy is hiding
underneath the car and slices his ankles
right
and then he starts [ __ ] crawling away
and like i i remembered this scene to
this day and that's why if i ever
approach a car i'm beating the system
first thing i'm doing i'm checking
underneath the car second thing i'm
doing i'm checking i'm checking the back
seat right
there there's no and like but then one
of deaths like
big big twist passengers look look look
if there's a sequel if there's like
urban legends too where there's like
there's like someone adds on to this
system i'm [ __ ] right but until then
i'm checking underneath every car i go
to and every back seat if i'm by myself
because i'm not getting my ankle sliced
off i'll tell you that much how did this
man
that's a nitpick but yeah how do they
use a scythe in a car what was this like
i don't know suv
you can't swing it in a car
the scythes are not short tools maybe a
sickle circle might have worked i like
how that's your first question and not
how did he get into the car yeah
yeah the first thing i was thinking when
he said this like how did this man swing
a scythe in a car i can barely swing my
arms in a car
that's a good question i should have
asked that as a kid apart maybe if he
you know he kind of like put it forward
and then brought it backwards but how
would you slice it underneath i feel
like if you stand you know there's a lot
of ways this could go wrong you're being
you're being a little too like realistic
here right right yeah we first have to
question why is death in my car
like i'm like i was going to be scared
until the many plot holes that were
available i suddenly feel a lot safer
irrational yeah i feel like this is good
you know i feel like as an adult you can
pick apart the plot holes in a lot of
horror movies and that's they stopped
being scary that's true as a kid you're
like
no no he's bleeding he's bleeding what
the [ __ ] i get i get that like back seat
like [ __ ] because like there's a lot
of like japanese horror films as well
that's like that's like a very cliche
the other one that scares me is uh
and i hated this because my new place
that i currently have has this but in
the bathroom your mirror has a medicine
cabinet
like you're brushing your teeth and then
you know
the medicine cabinet's slightly yeah and
then you close the medicine cabinet and
then the monster is standing behind you
right it's like
every now and then i have that thing
where like if i'm like in the dark and
the medicine cabinet is open before i
close it i just
look behind me
like do you like take a single breath
before you close you're just like okay
yeah
yeah i'm kind of like i see it open i'm
like
any rituals like that to like stop me
from being scared of something like that
i don't know i just i feel like
i i think to this day there's some part
about me where it's like i'm still
scared of the dark yeah right because
for what for what [ __ ] reason right
like it's not because it's like i'm
afraid of the guy behind me you know as
i'm at the medicine cabinet or whatever
but it's like you know in the back of
your head in the back of your [ __ ] up
imagination somewhere you're like yeah
this is a possibility it's like when
you're i don't know when you're sleeping
and you're like did i leave my door open
yeah you know you didn't but now you're
gonna go check yeah yeah cause you're
like i thought i did but i definitely
didn't but i'm gonna have to show you
all right
it's kind of like that where you like
you make yourself think something is
there so now you have to check exactly
otherwise you can't stop thinking about
it i think i had stuff like that with
like yeah there's there could be a
monster on the other side of the bed if
i turn around but i won't know unless i
turn around i guess i won't turn around
i have had thoughts like that but i
never actually like even wanted to
practice even when i think like oh i
could just like die if there was like a
guy standing in my hole with a knife i
don't actually like think that he's
going to be there but i check
but like i know you check just in case
there's no way in hell someone's there
yeah but you just have to confirm it
because i i i also get that every now
and again where it's like the most
irrational thoughts um where you know
sometimes there's you know you close the
door and you're like
maybe there's a guy on the other side
maybe there's someone in my house right
now yeah i i don't know and especially
like especially in the night time and
you like [ __ ] you [ __ ] hear
something in the middle of the night
in in like your living room yeah and
you're like i know there's nothing in my
house
but what if so what was that it was a
what if i like i'm pretty sure there's
no ghosts in my house i don't you know
my confidence my belief of ghosts that
this place isn't [ __ ] haunted or
whatever even if you know there might be
some haunted places in the world i'm
pretty sure this place is not in the
haunted
but then what the [ __ ] was that noise
like it could be the wind definitely not
the one
definitely the wind definitely not the
wind
you start second-guessing yourself you
know exactly and i feel that like
especially recently with like some
horror games i played like i feel that
just like resurfaced yeah it's it's not
until you recently consume content like
that that you start to realize oh yeah i
think i'm still afraid of this [ __ ] like
yeah i remember after i played pt for
the first time yeah like that made me so
late i was like hallways lights on
everywhere i go
like i'm not i'm not turning this [ __ ]
off [ __ ]
like so it's like it's so irrational
it's like of course the [ __ ] she's
not gonna be standing there at the end
of the hallway irrational fear that
someone who's close to you is like not
okay and then you just text him like are
you okay
i get that i get it yeah yeah yeah
you're like yeah
i had this weird dream just checking in
that you're all right you haven't texted
me in a while
we're good you're good
so sometimes i'm just like sometimes you
go to like a night out or like you hang
out with someone and you're just like
they didn't they said like 10 words less
than what they usually said
maybe there's something going on they
were blinking a lot more than usual
they were signaling something yeah
morse code maybe
oh my god no but like yeah like i think
part of the reason why i have so many
lights on my house is because it's
because of irrational fears like this
like my mom would [ __ ] bollock me as
a kid because every time my but my mom
and dad would go out they'd come home to
a house full of lights and they
and for the longest time i think they
just thought i would forget to turn off
the lights and i never just told them no
i'm just actually scared
what if there's like darkness and what
if there's something hiding in that
darkness mom you don't know i mean i'm
in this house by them by myself
they died in the dark exactly you never
know exactly what if squid game just
happens in your room while you're
sleeping you have to start defending
yourself
some
i didn't come to the realization of
course not the realization but
like the appreciation of just
lights
oh my god especially camping especially
camping right you really do appreciate
lights and fire the appreciation of life
oh my god oh my goodness
it's pretty good yeah i think being warm
is uh a vital part light's pretty
underrated
there's just just some things you just
like you know clothes is actually pretty
useful honestly they're pretty hard they
are yeah no [ __ ] they are con look i've
i'm just saying okay i've never
appreciated a hot shower more than after
we came back from that camping trip
i could just like turn on the hot water
and immediately just warm myself up yeah
i'm just like damn man this this shower
is hitting different
it is hitting different man that wasn't
the best shower and sleep i had though
when we came back it was so good yeah i
actually think that fixed my sleeping
schedule because i've been getting up at
like a reasonable time yeah yeah since i
got back from that uh ever since i did i
knocked out at like 9 00 pm dude yeah i
was so dumb
so i was like
so yeah anything else you guys want to
bring up or anything no just want to let
you know that
no clickbait in this episode we did
actually almost die twice three times if
you include you know the surprise attack
from the bush
was this close to death i'm surprised
jason almost died from from getting
scared by his own piss stream i'm just
saying i love you cuz but uh [ __ ] you at
the same time for literally like an
[ __ ] cousin
uh he's seven years older than me so
he's already a teenager yeah that's
pretty well he's the clown he's the
closest thing i have to an older brother
and that's thinking about that's a very
older brother this is a very old i love
you guys you you are like an older you
are like an older brother to me but also
[ __ ] you for showing me that all those
[ __ ] horror movies as a kid
oh it's so terrifying i remember one
thing for some reason it sticks out my
mind my old brother teaching me he's
like yeah you know what socks are for
right and i was like no what a socks for
he's like to clean up the the messes
that you spill on the floor
and i'm like oh what
that makes a lot of sense like when you
when you're holding a cup of tea and you
spill it on the floor it's like step one
just use yourself and i was like i was
like
i don't know if that's the dumbest thing
ever or if it's an actual life hack and
i was like you know what that's kind of
big break it's kind of big if it's not
like a big spill obviously if it's big
don't just start putting that's an awful
piece no it's not it's a little bit a
little spill if you have some thick
socks
there is nothing worse than wet socks
what for like a brief moment your body
how much water how much water are we
talking about like a tiny bit of
spillage on a cup of tea or something
and then you and then you rub it on the
carpet to like warm it up and dry it off
if it's if it's a spill that you can
actually feel on your like on your foot
on the surface i do for a brief moment
i still do it to this day but but hey
the floor's clean it's like it's like
kicking ice under the fridge what do you
mean when you spill ice you kick it
under the fridge that's a nice thing
i mean i don't do it anymore but
yeah you know you don't put it in the
sink and if you drop the ice while
you're like popping it yeah
okay well it depends on how much ice
comes out do two or three cubes just
kind of
get it under there just kick it under
just damage the floor you know did you
rather teach you that as well no i did
that
that's what you're gonna that's what
you're gonna teach your kid when uh when
you
kick the ice this is a trash chase life
hacks this is like a reverse life hacks
[ __ ] you shouldn't do
you think i'm going to ruin family mart
socks like that exactly come on you're
going to put them in the wash after no
that's that's that's all that's like
white if it's black just i only have
black socks although i mean that's your
life yeah just buy black socks don't
think
does that mean you don't own family mart
socks no i don't
i'm fine with not doing that i'm happy
with my socks i like having black socks
i don't have to think but if family mod
brought out a black sock variant
okay then the family might i hope you're
listening i mean you do need some black
socks yeah joey joey what looking at you
joey what i have black socks
you just never went
i swear to god every picture that's been
taken within like the past month i see
those [ __ ] family my socks poking out
identical i'm out of the outfit i
i have about nine pairs of family mask
socks and i just cycle through it every
week
they're poor supplier of songs like
working overtime dude it's like they're
amazing poor factory workers please
bring out a blackberry overtime
just going back to like a random thing
like okay i gotta ask you all right so
you hear something in the living room
right yeah maybe you're half asleep how
does aki handle that she's like go to
the living room she wants you to check
it yeah she's like uh sweetie can you go
check it i'm like woman what the [ __ ]
why am i the one to go
you're the one that's curious you go
yeah yeah yeah i i hate it right because
i'm not scared until they ask me to
check and i feel like i swear like their
fear gets like transferred over to me
because i'm just like yeah because like
that i was like you know before that i
was just like oh i guess uh something
knocked over and this is just a piece of
wind and then i
come on come on i hear something in the
i guess i'm in the living room go on go
check it go on i'm like sydney it's
probably nothing god i need you to go
check it now yeah i'm like [ __ ] me okay
now that i'm going to check now i'm like
and then resident evil music starts
playing in my hand i was like oh my god
there's a zombie in the living room and
then like i have i have to if i'm going
to check the living room even if i know
it's nothing i have to find a possible
weapon just in case just just in case
just in case you know and i i have to
like find something that i can smack a
possible animal or a person with yeah
just in case an animal
i don't know what the [ __ ] it could be
it could be a [ __ ]
if it's an animal i'm near certain you
would hear a lot more noise it would
probably be breaking it maybe they're
sneaky i don't know
that's how i discovered the [ __ ] last
week
did your houses have chimneys no you
just slept in the house with a chimney
no they make a lot of noise do they yeah
like unsettling noises
because oh no i i have i have had i had
i did live in house with the jimmy as a
kid and uh
uh it was blocked up but it still made
like the oh when it's open in fact the
noises that those make are like [ __ ]
terrifying yeah like
wolf howling all the time
literally like the stereotypical ghost
noise yeah
yeah it could be pretty scary sometimes
what if it's not the wind what if it's
just a bunch of ghosts
[Music]
from all the ghosts from all the guards
that got killed in bushes
hey man i need the statistics of how
many people have been killed while
pissing next to a bush
i just need to put my mind at me i'm
going to bet that most of the deaths are
from electric fences and then peeing on
them yeah probably something like that
or or an animal coming out or something
you know like a bear coming out i don't
know
what i'm worried about joey i'm worried
about a [ __ ] animal coming out or
something you know you'll hear it you'll
[Music]
and you will see it violently moving
yeah you'll see it even though you're
there you'll you'll see it like on the
top i know man jurassic park has told me
different jurassic park ain't [ __ ] come
on it's a great movie but ain't it
i'm used to england man we have nothing
be scared of in england
japanese policemen randomly stopping you
in the middle of the field asking you to
be checked as opposed to it i'm going to
wrestle if you're a japanese policeman
coming out of the boys you're like oh
you can't be here you have a more chance
of a japanese people than stopping you
from peeing in a bush when you do from
an animal or something killing you i'd
rather get arrested than uh violently
murdered by an animal man well that's
all that's all i'm saying i want to be
caught with your dick down and a
flashlight standing on you no that is
not what you want
that is true i know that's been our
irrational fears on trash